翻訳: Kumika Moore
校正: Hiroko Kawano
あの 先に言っときますけど
この椅子あんまり意味はないんです
尺八が出て 歌手が出て
芸人を挟んで ペッパーが出て
私 トークだけなので
心もとないんで
これ置いたってことなんですけど
（笑）
なので期待しないでください
私もともと医者をしてたんです
でも今は病院で働かずに 起業しています
何をしてるかというと
健康でいられる時間と寿命
そのギャップ
まあ「ヘルスライフギャップ」
そういったものを
どう解消するかに取り組んでます
将来 今を振り返った時に
「あの頃って どうやって
健康を守ってたんだっけ？」
そう思わせたいっていうのが願いなんです
医者でMBAで起業してるなんて言うと
いかにもグローバル課題を
イノベーティブにシンプルになんていう
いわゆる セクシービジネスモデル
みたいなのを期待されちゃうんですけども
僕みたいな社会起業家にとっては
そんなきれいな言葉よりも
実はもっとローカルで
複雑な課題を地道に解決する
そっちの方がずっと重要なんです
実は この話はこれで
１時間くらい喋れるんですけど
今日の本題ではないんです
肩透かしみたいで すみません
それから もう１つ
言っておきたいのは
僕は ここの出身なんですけども
母校でTEDxっていう場を与えられて
しかも大して優秀な学生でも
なかったんですけれども
この安田講堂の壇上で喋れるってのは
すごい有り難いことなので
この場を借りて ほんとに
感謝したいと思ってます
学生時代に 勉強をあんまり
してなかったって言いましたけれども
卒業してから
仕事しなかったわけでは当然なくて
きちんと医者をやってたんです
医者の仕事は 皆さんも
想像できるかもしれませんけども
すごい激務で
昼間は常に患者さん診ますし
夜は救急車に乗って通院する
患者さんを診るって
ずっと患者さんを診てるわけです
で 忙しすぎるので
家は ほとんど
寝るだけに帰る場所だったり
そもそも家があっても
病院に寝泊まりする
そんな生活をしています
ですから病院を離れた今でも
今働いている医療職の人たちを
いつも尊敬してるんです
で 医療は実は ―
「実は」と言うとアレですけど
皆さんご存知のように
何かしら困った人が病院にやって来て
その方々を助ける
そういう仕事です
しかも命を扱ってますし
患者さんから感謝もされます
そうすると この「助けている」とか
「命を預かっている」
あるいは「感謝される」
こうしたことが ものすごい充実感になって
忙しい現場を支えています
私も かつてそうでした
医者仲間たちと
辛いな、苦しいなと思いながら
でも そのとてつもない充実感を感じて
仕事をしてたんです
でも一方で
こういう見方をすることもできます
「誰かが困って病院に来るまで
病院の中で待ってていいんですか？」
それって あたかも崖下で
上から落ちてくる人を待ってるような —
医療って そんなもんなんでしたっけ？
そういう違和感が
少し自分の中に芽生えたんです
で 私は臨床医という
病院で働く医者を６年やったんですけれども
ずっと 今言ったような違和感と
一方で感じる とてつもない充実感
その両方を感じて生きてきました
正直言うと 違和感の方からは目を背けて
医療を究めようと思って
日々 目の前のことに
一生懸命 取り組んで充実感を得る
そんな生活をしてました
確かに大きな病院の中の いち医者には
自分の感じてる違和感の原因も
解決策も分かんなかったわけです
それは自分の問題なのか
あるいは自分が その時
働いている病院の問題なのか
はたまた医療そのものの問題なのか
それすら当時の私には
診断ができなかったんです
でも そんな毎日を過ごしてるうちに
違和感がどんどん 溜まり溜まって
ある時どうしても我慢ができなくなって
その解決法[を]探しに
ビジネススクールに行くことにしました
で ビジネススクールに
行くことを決めた時に
周りの医療従事者、友人の医師たちは
口々に こう言いました
「医療 辞めんの？」
僕からすると
すごくびっくりしたのは
医療のあり方を突き詰めるために
ビジネススクールに行く
そういう選択をしたのに
周りからは「医療を辞めるんですか？」と
受け取られちゃうわけです
「困ったなあ」と思いながら
ビジネススクールに行きました
そしたら また次の驚きがありました
どんな驚きかというと
行った先で
自分がそれまで培ってきたもの
医学知識も臨床経験も
あるいは思考回路も
まったく役に立たなかったんです
ついでに言うとアメリカだったので
日本語も全然通じなくて
苦しい日々が続きました
で 実は２年間の
ビジネススクール留学だったんですが
その時の辛さを喋ろうと思ったら
たぶん３年間喋れるぐらいキツかったんです
（笑）
でも これも今日の本題ではないので
ここまでにしておきますが
そのぐらいキツかったんです
そもそもビジネススクールの学生が
何を論点に喋ってるのか
全然分かんないんです
彼らの思考回路も分かりません
だって僕からすると
「どっちでもいいじゃん 誰も死なないよ」
で終わっちゃうわけです
（笑）
でも そうする中で
あることに気付きました
今思えば すごく当たり前のことですし
みんな「そりゃそうだ」と思うと思うんですが
人はそれぞれ自分の価値観や
正義を持っています
で それはみんなバラバラだということ
まあ それは皆さん ちょっと
「言われなくても分かるよ」って感じですよね
そして意外なことに その正義や価値観
なかなか交わらないんです
逆に言うと
その正義には ある意味
半径みたいなものがあって
なかなか交わることがない
そんなことなんです
じゃあ どうして
そんなことに気付いたかというと
ビジネススクールというところに行って
「経営」っていう新しい視座を得て
僕は かつての自分の正義の中心や半径を
見つめ直す機会を得られたからです
そこで気付いたことは たくさんあります
例えば
私が医者の当時 感じていたもの
これは狭い正義
もっと言えば「診察室」という
半径５メートルぐらいの正義の中で
語っていた正義でした
で 確かに その診察室の中では
医療は まったく正しいんです
一方でビジネススクールに行くと
こういう人もいました
「短期でもいいから
大きな利益を上げられたら
それは成功じゃないか」
それは その正義としては
正しいと思います
でも聞いている皆さんも
どこかで分かるように
なんとなく違和感を感じないか
ということなんです
それは皆さんが 今お話しした
狭い正義の外から見た時に
「なんか おかしいな」
そう違和感を感じる
自分自身も
病院の中で通じてる正義、価値観が
病院の外に出ると まったく通じない
そのことに違和感を覚えつつ
充実感で ごまかしてきた
そんな自分が見えたわけです
もっといいこともありました
今お話ししたように
ビジネススクールに行って
「ああ 自分は医療の正義を持ってたんだな」
「それから経営の正義も手に入れた」
その先に今度は試行錯誤が始まったんです
どんな試行錯誤か
「この２つをどうやって
つなげればいいんだろう？」
よく言われる話に
病院の経営判断と臨床判断
医療の判断が ぶつかった時にどうするんだ
そういう問題があります
その試行錯誤を
ビジネススクールに行くこと
あるいは その後の生活ですることで
最終的に その２つを僕は
自分の中でつなげるようになりました
そして今では 例えば
「もはや医療の価値は
延命だけじゃないよね」
そういうことも受け入れられますし
経営、ビジネスにとって
医療はコストではなくて
社会の将来に対する投資なんだという
主張をすることもできます
ですから私にとって医療は
「難しい病気を治す」
それだけのためのものではなくて
どうやったら病気にさせないか
あるいは皆さんが
ずっと元気で過ごすために使えるもの
医療はそういうもんだと
気付いたわけです
今お話ししてきた ―
延命だけが医療の価値ではないことに
気付いて…という話でした
で それまでの道のりを思い返すと
いくつもキーになるポイントがあったんですが
今日は皆さんと３つ
ぜひ共有したいことがあります
１つ目は ここに出ているように
「目の前の物事を突き詰めてください」
ということです
「目の前の物事を突き詰める」というのは
自らの価値観や正義
それを育てる唯一の手段だと思いますし
何かの物事を成し遂げるための
最善の方法だと思います
物事を突き詰めると
一瞬 視野が狭くなる気がします
それを嫌がる人がいるのも知っています
「オプションが減るのはやだ」
「オプションは多い方がいい」
でも よく考えてほしいのは
いくら皆さんが人生の選択肢
オプションを持っていたところで
体は１つですし
時間は皆さんに平等だし
しかも有限なんです
選択することを避けて
時間を無駄にするぐらいだったら
一刻も早く
「目の前にある物事を突き詰める」
ということを通して
自分を鍛えたり
社会に貢献する道を選んでほしい
そう思います
２つ目
これは「微かな違和感を大事にする」
ということです
この微かな違和感こそが
皆さんが育てた価値観や正義を
見つめ直すきっかけでもあり
新しい道のりを開く魔法の扉でもあるんです
私自身もそうでした
最初の方に言ったように
日々の診療の中で感じてた違和感
これが積み重なって
新たな道のりを探しに行き
そして今の自分があるわけです
でも不思議なことに人は
この違和感 あるいは
自分に対するアラートが苦手です
なぜなら自分の正義の中にいる限りは
充実感も得られますし
どちらかというと
安心感、安定感も得られるからです
だからといって
このアラートに耳を塞いだり
あるいは知らないフリをして
自分に引きこもってしまうのは最悪なんです
というのは別の新しい価値観や
正義に出会った時に
良くても無視
悪いと攻撃するようなことを
してしまうからです
そうすると失うものは多くても
得るものは何にもないんです
これはとても勿体ないことだと思います
ですから この「微かな違和感を大事にする」
そういう姿勢を
常に大事にしてほしいと思います
そして３つ目
「試行錯誤を嫌がらない」
このことをお勧めします
試行錯誤こそが
新しい自分を削り出す貴重な時間です
私もそうでした
さっきも言ったように
医療と経営の２つの正義
自分の中にあった時に
「この２つをどうやってつなげよう」
「どうやって価値観を取捨選択して
自分なりに解釈しよう、納得しよう」
これは苦しい日々なんです
答えは自分の中にしかありませんから
自分と向き合う日々です
自分に問い続ける日々というのは
決して楽じゃないんです
でも ある時 何かのきっかけで
新しい自分が削り出されます
それとともに自分が
次に進むべき道のりだったり
その先に広がる世界を見ることができます
きっかけは様々です
かつては それがリンゴだったって人も
いるらしいというのは
聞いたことありますけれども
私の場合は まったく果物とか
そういうものはなくて
むしろ今回こうした場で
話すことができること自体
おそらく病院の中で
あの時はあの時で日々
悪戦苦闘してましたけれども
あの頃よりはアップグレードされたんだ
というふうに思います
そういう意味では
物事を突き詰めること
それから
日々の微かな違和感を大事にすること
そして試行錯誤を嫌がらないこと
こうしたことで今
自分が進むべき道が見えてきたな
そんなふうに思っています
さて今 そうは言いましたけれども
実は まだ試行錯誤が続いています
「続いている」というよりは
「また始めた」と言ってもいいかもしれません
世界規模の課題の一つである
「医療」という問題
そして その問題と世界でもっとも早く
向き合い始めた日本という国で
私は起業という選択肢をとって
その解決策を模索しました
正直 起業は超怖いんです
もともと ただの医者ですし
ビジネススクール行ったっていったって
ビジネスについて
勉強したっていうだけなんです
ですから私にとって起業するというのは
すごく怖かったんです
で 最悪なことに
起業した後 毎日怖いっていう
何なんだって話なんですね
起業する前にせっかく悩んだのに
してみたらもっと辛い
でも その試行錯誤の中で
今日お話ししたような
新しい自分が削り出されることを
知ってるので
ある意味で充実した日々だとも言えます
今私に見えている医療の姿
あるいは そこに至る道のりは
こんな感じです
「ずっと元気でいたい」
あるいは「ずっと元気でいてほしい」
そんな思いをカタチに変える医療
そうした医療を実現することが
私の理想であり
その道のりのための試行錯誤は いとわない
そう思えたのも
ここまでの道のりを導いてくれた
多くの出会いだったり
あるいは人生の貴重な時間を
一緒に過ごしてくれた ―
患者さんたちのおかげだと
すごく思ってます
そこはすごく感謝しています
ですから皆さんも おそらく
それぞれに課題だとか
悩みはあると思うんです
でも今お話ししたような
物事を突き詰める姿勢だったり
違和感を大事にする姿勢
それから試行錯誤を嫌がらない
そうしたことを大事にしてもらいたいな
というふうに思います
心配は無用です
全力を尽くしてください
無様でも もがいてください
でも 微かな違和感を大事にできる感性も
忘れないようにしてください
そうすれば必ず
新しい自分が削り出されて
今よりさらに充実した
新しい世界、道のりが見える
私はそう信じています
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）